okay good evening thank you for being
here this evening as
most of you already know we've received
a court order
to keep 30 of our voting sites open
until 8 pm
we've been in the process of contacting
all of those sites and the facilities
we have been successful in doing so we
don't anticipate any trouble in having
the extended hours
at any of our facilities
we've had hundreds of people working for
many many weeks
and leading into the election with
everything that's new this year
it's a tremendous amount of effort that
we have with our staff
i have to commend them it's been a very
challenging year not just for the
election support but
with the pandemic several challenges
that uh were unexpected but they've done
an excellent job in providing access
for voters in clark county
earlier we did have technical issues
that we experienced at sites
the majority of those issues dealt with
connectivity and the setup of our poll
books where we signed people in to vote
in some cases we had a few issues very
small but there were some issues with
machines
are they throughout the day
it's in the morning connectivity is an
issue that we experience throughout the
day
much like people who go home after five
when a majority of the public starts to
sign in
on their smart devices there's a slow in
the connectivity of all of their devices
we experience that all day long so it's
a challenge that we deal with
we had good admin rover support today
they were able to respond and we did get
all polling places back up and running
nothing out of the ordinary and again we
have a strong team of admin rovers who
travel throughout the valley
we quickly respond we had a tremendous
amount of support
from local law enforcement along with
the mac center that was open today and
the secretary of state
with the support that we had we were
able to handle all issues
voters leading into election day we had
378 000
early voters and we had reported a
little over 400 000 mail ballots
received we're still in the process of
crossing
assessing some of those but the
challenges that we dealt with were
tremendous
the pandemic being one of the most major
has
and it resulted in what we had to do in
the primary election we made
considerable changes to make sure that
we had an increase in access we went
from one election day polling
three excuse me election day polling
sites in the primary and one early
voting site
to 35 sites that were open for 14 days
and 125 vote centers that were available
today for voting so
putting all that together getting the
poll workers uh dealing with the
poll worker group that is majority of
seniors who were more susceptible to the
pandemic
was a challenge that we dealt with
consistently but we were successful
in getting the workers that we needed so
no absolutely not we have mail coming in
there are mail ballot drop-off locations
at all 125 of our sites plus the
election department
plus the u.s mail we're required to wait
for those to come in as well so what you
see tonight will be an unofficial report
and it won't be final until november
16th
today i don't know if it was a record
turnout for for the in person
because it's difficult to gauge because
there was drop off and we don't know how
many there are there but early voting
the mail that we received so far and our
in-person early voting was definitely a
large increase
in what we've seen in the past
well we're not done yet so i can't
really give you that report however
during the course of the day we had
lines that were
average i would say that the turnout
today the last time we checked was at
about 68 000
which is a considerable amount lower
than what we normally see
election day we were prepared to handle
well over two hundred thousand voters on
election day but we're
not going to get anywhere near that
well without a doubt the early voting we
had a full early voting program in fact
we had three more sites this year
than we did in 2018 as was required
through ab4
and then the vote centers that we put in
place it's 122 more sites so
yes
well the report is going to be later
obviously and it'll
probably affect the whole state because
we can't report in any county in the
state of nevada until the secretary of
state
has confirmed with us that all voters
are done in the entire state of nevada
so as a result of us staying open until
8 pm
it's going to slow down the election
results coming out
machines do not come back to the polling
to the election center
they start being picked up tomorrow as
far as the ballots
they are secured by the two team leaders
that are assigned at each vote center
and they will be bringing those back
tonight with us but the police
escort is for our transport from trade
drive to graystone where we process
ballots
[Music]
sure it's important that if the general
public is not confident in the integrity
of the process
that they're not confident that their
vote counts then
the election isn't effective and so
we've always worked here it's been our
number one priority
to uphold the integrity and everything
that we do although we've seen a
tremendous increase in the number of
male ballots
we have been doing male ballots for many
years and so we had to
redefine our processes to handle the
number of mail ballots however
we were very comfortable with the
process that we had in place
every presidential election for an
election official is the biggest
election they've done
especially in a jurisdiction like clark
county where we have continued growth
this is my eighth presidential election
so i would have to say that this has
probably been the most difficult
election i've ever had to support
[Music]
absolutely the pressure has come from
many different groups both parties uh
third-party community
uh partners that we have in the
community everybody was very engaged in
this election and wanted to make sure
that their vote was going to count and
that our processes would hold up
with the changes that we've had as a
result of the pandemic
and going to all mail for all active
registered voters
so we have also been doing a tremendous
amount of outreach with our general
public
through psas and also in doing several
zoom meetings uh with different groups
to make sure that they were aware of the
changes
and aware of all of the access that we
were working hard to provide
it was a challenge and we had to make
sure that
we were providing a process that made
them feel comfortable
that they would have access to the
ballot and i believe we were successful
that comes with a job that's not unique
to this election
i'm an umpire in the worst baseball game
in the world and i have to keep it fair
and so that's
if you're not prepared for that you
shouldn't be an election official
well we can't close the pose until late
and if you're in line at eight o'clock
at any of those 30 sites
we're gonna put a staffer at the end of
the line so there's no guarantee
that those sites will close at eight we
will continue to process voters
if they're in line at eight o'clock so
it's difficult for me to predict
exactly when but it's going to be later
than we anticipate
so there were 125 boat centers
throughout clark county each one of
those locations
has to return our flash drive so that we
can read them into the system
we will verify that all cartridges have
been received
before we close out on our final
unofficial report for this evening
all of those team leaders will come
through the doors directly behind me
and they'll be bringing in paperwork uh
bail ballot drop-off boxes
to be secured and the flash drives that
we need to read into the system so all
of that needs to be complete before we
can put out our final unofficial